a quote from Julia Cameron of the
artists way and many other incredible
works is uh it takes constant vigilance
not to slip into negativity or simple
apathy it takes courage to believe that
over a given period of time we are
getting better and not sliding into
decline so how does someone who has been
possibly in industry for a long time
whether success or not strengthen this
stance you know it seems like for those
who have maybe not made it quote-unquote
there's maybe a depression and a
bitterness that success will never come
and then for those possibly that have me
that there's sometimes a feeling of
being trapped and dictating by dictated
by the controls of money and not
creativity so how do we stay at the
craft of writing and keep it fresh the
summon that feeling the longer that you
are in the business of right that you
start to get trapped in the lack of
creativity as a serious problem this is
an industry and it's all about it's
either got to make money or we don't
work and so there's there's constantly
this pressure to write the commercial
script and it is one of the worst things
that you can fall fall prey to because
what you then do is you start trying to
predict what will be commercial and that
is impossible I don't care how long
you've been doing it you can't do it
even if you were to come up with a
somewhat close prediction of what is
going to be hot by the time you wrote
that script got it through all the
machinations that are required for the
business it would that moment of being
hot is arguable and it's probably two
years past so you can't do it this is
why it is so important for writers no
matter how successful
and in fact the more successful you are
the more important this is to constantly
be challenging your own creativity yes
you do have to have certain elements for
example genre elements that will appeal
to a mass audience but you don't have to
write a generic script you don't have to
write a paint-by-numbers machine script
that you think will be commercial that's
the quickest way to fail and it's also
the quickest way to get down on yourself
psychologically and not want to write
anymore
it's one reason what a lot of writers
give up but the creativity is your
responsibility there is no reason that
every script you write can't be
something that is personally very
meaningful to you and that the
techniques that you use to write that
script or have a number of unique
creative elements in so it's strictly up
to you but again that goes back to also
knowing the craft knowing that the big
part of the craft of writing is not just
knowing the beats of a particular genre
story but also forcing yourself to hit
those beats in a creative way that you
or the rest of the audience has never
seen before
so I put the onus onto the writer there
and I think that it's a false and an
easy step that we take to say oh it's
their fault it's the business you know
they they make us write this way no they
don't it's it's only if you buy into
that mythology that you write that way
but remember I always tell writers this
you can have a lot more ideas in this
life than you ever have time to write
a full-length script or not so always
write a story that you both care about
and that you think will have an appeal
to a larger audience it can always be
done
you